- [Interviewer] Perfect. So
tell me where you grew up.
Where did you grow up?
- I grew up South central Los Angeles.
105th Deacon, Western.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] And you were
in gangs when you were a kid.
- [Arthur] Oh yeah
- [Interviewer] What-What
age did you enter the gang?
- [Arthur] Probably about eleven.
Yeah. About 11 years old.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- I'm 58 now.
- [Interviewer] 58. So back then,
gangs were probably, quite a bit different
than what they are now, right?
- Uh.. it was..
- [Interviewer] More violent am I right?
- Yeah. It basically more violent now,
because yeah we wasn't in the guns,
and stuff back then.
- [Interviewer] Yeah more fighting?
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Yes more fighting,
Yeah it was all about them hits.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
the tools have change.
- Yeah, the tools just change,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah for real.
- [Interviewer] So tell
me about your childhood?
You grew up with one parent?
- I grew up with my
grandmother and my mother,
grandmother raised me.
Mother lived in the back house,
us and grandma and the
kids stayed in the front.
You know what I'm saying?
I have some little brothers
that the half brothers
they moved to Compton and yeah, they,
they really got wild down there.
- [Interviewer] What gang were you in?
- Hoover.
- [Interviewer] Hoover?
- Hoover yeah
- [Interviewer] Was that bloods or crips?
What is it?
- That's a- now it's a gang all to itself.
It's not a blood or crip,
- [Interviewer] Oh I see
- but it started off as a crip though.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
It started off as a crip.
Now stay like they can get along
with who they want to get along with
and get it on with whoever
wants to get it on, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- Yeah. I like it better like this though.
- [Interviewer] It was.. so
have you had prison time?
- 20 years.
- [Interviewer] 20 years?
- 20 years on installment plan.
- [Interviewer] What for?
- Just some of everything, armed robbery,
attempted murder,
burglaries,
drugs.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] I mean, so
back when you were a kid,
entering the gang were
there other options for you
or was it like the only thing to do?
- For me?
It was probably like the only
thing to do it was, it was
it was the only thing to do, you know?
I mean, yeah, you have those people who,
whose mommas is real, real hard on me
and keep them in the house and stuff.
And, and those dudes are
kind of really messed up now
you know what I'm saying?
But most of the ones I knew
that was kept like that
and mine tried to do to do me like that
but I didn't let them.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- You know, I didn't have most.
I was, I was running
with the wild bunch at a
really young age, 11 years old.
I didn't have a friend under 12.
- [Interviewer] What they were...
- They were all 16 to
18, 19, 20 years old.
- [Interviewer] Yeah big age gap.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell me some,
crazy stories about being in a gang.
- I was that kid that
you couldn't hang around
with, if you was my age
and I tried to come play
with you at your house and stuff.
You can't be around me.
You couldn't be around me.
I had to go, I had to
go, know what I'm saying?
(laughs)
I couldn't ride your bike.
I couldn't do nothing.
So I windup taking the
bikes and stuff like that.
Just spiteful.
Just be a spiteful.
Know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] And what was your first,
run of the law?
- First run with the law,
I was eleven years old
armed robbery or not armed robbery, strong
armed robbery.
I made two dudes give me their money.
- [Interviewer] At how old?
- At eleven years old.
- [Interviewer] Eleven?
- Yeah. And I didn't get no time for it,
or nothing you know I'm saying?
back then I was going to jail, getting out
and going to jail,
getting out like same day.
You know what I'm saying?
As long as mama gonna come
get you and my grandma always
came to get me, you know what I'm saying?
So I didn't, I didn't
spend over 24 hours in jail
until maybe about 16.
16 years old, you know?
And that started going to camps,
Y.A's, then prison.
- [Interviewer] Did you
finish high school or...
- I have a GED.
I have a GED.
One time I got out of
jail and I put my age
up to 18 and went to job
Corps, Clearfield, Utah.
And I got my GED.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You have kids?
- Yes, I have- I have twins.
I have a set of twins and an older son.
- [Interviewer] Do you see your kids?
- I see my kids sporadically.
Now my son is in prison
and my son is in prison.
He has about three more
years to do some, yeah
- [Interviewer] What was he in prison for?
- A life slavery or something like that?
You know what I'm saying?
There's some crazy stuff.
He was a, he was a
little pimp, my son yeah
and he's a little pimp.
And, but my other two kids
they're in college and stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
Southwest, one is in Southwest
and one is in El Camino.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Yeah one of them is
in El Camino and stuff.
Yeah. I was, I was in prison
two different states on parole,
in two different states at the same time,
you know what I'm saying?
It's crazy.
(sirens)
They tried to three-strike
me in California twice
(sirens)
before the law came out,
already had four strikes.
You know what I'm saying?
Before the law even came into
existence, I was struck out.
- [Interviewer] You
were struck out before,
they even struck you out?
- Yeah, so the catch me with drugs
and he talking about giving
me more time than OJ.
I was in there with OJ, the bicycle man,
the pizza man and all the
first people that got 29
to life in a better, you
know what I'm saying?
And they told me, they're
going to, if I get found guilty
they're going to give
me more time then OJ's
gonna get.
I think the most OJ
could of got was 25 years
and they was going to give me 35.
- [Interviewer] Wow
- If, if I'm guilty.
And it was only for
dope. It wasn't for no..
Anyway, I started selling dope.
I started selling dope
and I was bored as hell.
And because of my boredom,
I had been already
robbing
pimps.
I started off robbing pimps.
I didn't like pimps too much.
I didn't like what they did to the ladies.
You know what I'm saying the beating?
And I didn't, I didn't like that.
And I started robbing pimps,
and then my- my talents improved,
and I started robbing jewelry stores.
I robbed nine jewelry stores.
Never been caught for one.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- Never been caught for one.
I aint tell you about this
girl named Peaches, because
at the same, I live my life
by the old laws of the Bible.
You know what I'm saying?
I believe I can have
five wives, I don't care
what Americans say, what
anybody says about it.
I can have five wives if I want, you know
almost like the state of Utah.
Now, you know what I'm saying?
They've been doing it.
But so have I, you know what I'm saying?
Even now it's still have,
I have more than one
you know what I'm saying?
But still to do a Peaches,
she was something else.
She was, she was from Harlem crip
and I'm from Hoover.
And she, our, our, our sets
didn't really, really get along.
But in the beginning of
our sets, we did get along.
So I'm from that era.
But even in the era
that we didn't get along
I still got along with
some people that I got
along with at first, because
of my age, I'm older.
So I can go back to the beginnings
of these hoods, you know?
And, and you know, the
people that do know me
and they would rather kill one
of their own and do anything to me.
You know what I'm saying?
Because were that cool, were that tight.
So anyway, this girl Peaches,
I gave her so much game.
She turned,
gay on me.
And started wanting to be a man too.
You know what I'm saying?
I gave her so much game,
she thought she was a man too.
And, and she used it in right now.
She's probably still using
it up in Hollywood somewhere.
If I ever run into her,
I like you to meet her.
You know what I'm saying?
Maybe you can see
something to, I don't know
but I never knew she was
going to turn out that way.
But anyway, I started training her
to rob the way I was trained.
I was trained as first a getaway driver.
And I started training her as that
you know what I'm saying?
I showed her how to, to keep going.
You know what I'm saying?
To keep going.
Tactic is no matter what lane you in.
If you see a stop light but its room
to get in the right lane,
and make that right turn.
You see what I'm saying is
at the first available time
you know, I keep going,
you know what I'm saying?
It's clear, move on, bus that right.
When you get away from a crime,
you know what I'm saying?
And I trained, I was
training her like that.
And she became a pretty good driver.
You know what I say?
Cause I was a great driver.
Yeah. And, and then slash
baggage because I started robbing
by myself and then I
pulled her in and she did
she did three weeks with me here.
I'll say she did.
She did three licks with me.
Licks?
A lick is a- the hitting
of the doing of a job.
And she did three with me.
And one of them, I got shot the hell up.
I got shot all in my back
and I'm in my back arm right here.
The bullet, you see bullet hole,
elbow-elbow right here, I got shot.
I been shot nine times.
And, and, and what else?
Couple in the leg, but anyway, Peaches.
And that was my little
heart though at the time
but I was married, but so
I had her and my first wife
Anita.
That's another story but anyway
(laughs)
Peaches, Peaches was something else.
I started showing her how to robs.
So I'd going into places
with me with pistol,
and Oh she'd be kind of like a gazelle.
I'm telling you, she
(gunshot imitation)
she would jump a counter,
and boom, everybody down.
Boom. If you know what I'm
saying, let everybody down, boom
and go straight to the
case and bust the case open
and boom, get it, get money,
know what I'm saying and get money.
Oh, that girl, was something else.
But one time, this one time
she saved me right here.
I pulled a pistol.
She leaked the counter, went
to her counter and started hitting
and security was in there
that I didn't know about.
And he shot me.
He shot the hell out of me.
Bow, he shot me in my elbow, spun around.
And when I spun around
the bullet was, you know,
the velocity of the bullet.
Spun me all the way around.
And when I came back, my
gun was pointed at him.
So of course I hit him.
Boom, boom, boom.
I hit him three times.
You know what I'm saying?
The fool fell out, boom ,
got up and made it to the back.
He made to the back.
But he went in the back
and I didn't pay him no more attention.
I hit the counter it's I hit my count,
my, my, my case.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause she was already hitting
those cases out there.
I started hitting in my case
and the fool came out
and again, boom, boom.
Boom, he dumped on me again
and it hit me three times right here.
You know what I'm saying?
I fell into the cave.
Bam, shoo blood everywhere.
I fell onto the case,
and my girls yelled my name and stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
And I turned around
and I started dumping at
the security guard again.
Boom, boom.
And he turned around and ran, ran.
And he went upstairs.
It was, I guess it was a jewelry front,
but you can go in the back
it had storage some shit upstairs.
Cause you ran up the stairs.
He ran up the stairs.
Cause he ran out of bullets
cause he had a big ass, three 57 Magnum.
But he had 38 load in it and birdshot.
Cause some of the bird
shot hit me in the back.
The bird shot shells is a 38 load
with the blue plastic tip
with a buckshot in it.
You know what I'm saying?
He hit me with that like
two times in my back
so I have buckshot all in my back
and bullet hole here.
And bullet holes here from that robbery.
And so anyway, we get
the jewelry and stuff.
She yelled my name and she ran
over to me and asked him I was all right.
Cause I fell all the way
up into the damn case.
You know what I'm saying?
And yeah, so we got up and
she helped me out the store.
Cause I lost a lot of blood and stuff.
So I was kind of weak and stuff.
So boom, we get in the car,
boom and get away driving.
We're driving away.
We're in a Cadillac.
All tinted windows.
Yeah. Would we driving out
- [Arthur] Yeah, but the
windows wasn't that dark
of a tint and you can see through it.
You know what I'm saying?
We stopped.
We stopped at this light,
the police that roads block
for us all through downtown Sacramento.
So it's had stop here
and turn and go in here.
We turned into an
underground apartment stall.
They have parking
underground parking stall.
They had parking underground,
so we turned into there, boom we stopped.
I jumped and she was like, Oh baby.
Cause I had a bag for the jewelry
and I wouldn't had no money at all
because when I was getting
mine, I got shot in the back.
Boom, boom, boom.
And I dropped everything.
But luckily she had got a bag of jewelry
boom but she didn't know how much.
I didn't know how much at the time.
But she handed me the bag
and she said run baby,
you know what I'm saying?
And she was going to stay right there
because we turned into the road block
and we thought the police
seen us, but they didn't .
You know?
So we turned into road block.
So I'm standing here.
My arm was throbbing its feeling
like I had a heart beating in my arms.
Ba boom, baboon, baboon.
So I had, I had to hold my arm up.
(laughs)
I went into this,
(laughs) I went into the laundry mat,
of the apartment was
down in this basement,
area and I was in the basement
and I was holding on to this
damn wall pipe overhead.
And I was like, baby roll me a Primo.
So I'm smoking cocaine.
And this, primo-primo is a cocaine
and a marijuana rolled up together.
Remember I told you I
smoked primo for 30 years
20 years without ever smoking the pipe.
So this was during that time I did so
and I was pretty oh crazy.
I was smoking like a
thousand dollars a day.
I was on one of the
richest biggest drug dealer
chiefs in LA.
You know what I'm saying?
A known member, you know
I was holding my hand
up and up over the pipe.
My arm was beating, baboon.
but it stopped beating as severe,
When I held it up over my head
I guess the blood didn't run up to it.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- So boom, so I'm holding on this pipe
and my girl goes and
gets a tie out of the car
and wraps it around my
arm, boom this elbow
this elbow, cause the
elbow is where you could
feel this right here.
I still have a piece of the
bullet in this thing right here.
I have arthritis on cold days.
It's like, Ooh, it hurts
real bad because I never went
to a doctor because I didn't know
- [Interviewer] Oh really
- whether, you know I
killed the guy or not.
You know what I'm saying?
To this day still.
So please guys.
But anyway,
I don't think he died
because he did get up
and he ran, and upstairs,
you know what I'm saying?
And I ran out.
There was a buzz- buzz
sound and whoever who,
whoever I laid, she laid down
when she jumped the counter,
stayed hitting the button.
(imitating buzz sounds)
So they was holding the door.
Like, please hurry up and get what y'all
gonna get and get the
hell up out my store.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Right.
- So they end up still holding the button.
So we ran out, we went out the door
and all that other stuff
happened when I told you
holding your hand up on the thing.
So I'm still holding
the handle on the thing.
Holding my hand up for about 30 minutes.
and then bring my hand
down, look at my watch.
I think it's shift change.
You know what I'm saying?
For the afternoon shift changed.
So I said, you know what?
I bet you, these road blocks are down.
You know what I'm saying?
My driver was still out in the car.
You know he's sitting there smoking,
smoking crack, you know?
Cause I have plenty of crack.
You know, he was smoking, she was smoking.
She smoked crack too.
She was smoking.
I had smoked me a joint, primo
but they smoked a pipe.
And so they smoking it.
So I come back and get in the car boom.
I'm getting a car and we drive.
I said come on
lets just drive, drive regular
and let's get back to the hood.
Right. So boom.
We get back to the motel.
I open the back.
She had so many got damn
diamonds, I mean she had
so many diamonds and diamonds.
I said, Ooh baby, she said, Oh baby here.
She said all I want she wanted a Jeep.
She wanted a Jeep car and
a bud sack, okay baby.
I think you got that in
here with me having mine.
I think you've got that in here.
I'm going to give you that ride.
So I went to my peoples.
So now I'm back with the bag of jewelry.
He say, what you got there Arthur?
Started playing with the
bag, on the front porch.
I said, I don't know.
I got to that a jewelry, you know,
he said jewelry.
What? Come here and see what you got.
You know what I'm saying now,
so- so
He let me in clank, clank he let me in
So now I'm back in.
So he let me in and so
he listed everything
you know, saying, he said,
okay, give me an hour.
And I'll tell you what it's worth.
You know, I trust this man with my life.
So it was no problem for me leave
every bit of jewelry that I had with me
with him, you know?
And there was no problem at all.
I -I can't left it with him.
When I came back.
He said you said you have between,
76 and 85 thousand
dollars worth of jewelry.
I said what?
He said, yeah.
He said, he said, what do you want?
I said half you know what I'm saying?
he said, half 50 percent, man.
I can't give you 50 percent.
I can give you 25% of
the, long story short.
He windup giving me 35
thousand dollars cash.
You know what I'm saying?
He windup given me 35
thousand dollar cash.
Okay. So, so, so I say 35 thousand cash.
Okay. What can I do?
So I bought, I brought three Cadillac's
and I didn't buy Peaches her Jeep,
but I bought her a kilogram of
Kush bud
which was very specific at the time.
I think it's sold for
like 5 hundred dollars.
I think I paid like 15 to
17 hundred dollars for her,
a pound of bud.
And she remembers, she said
she wanted some weed and a Jeep
so she could start her
own little business.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- You know what I'm saying?
And even then I had given her so much game
she was ready to be out on her own.
It start her own little business
of her selling weed.
You know what I'm saying?
She never sold pussy,
but she was fine as a motherfucker.
And I told her, you know,
and she didn't like pimps
because I didn't like pimps
because I used to rob pimps.
So you know what I'm saying?
And I remember one time a pimp told her
he just saw her walking to a gas station.
We pulled up in the gas station
in a '84 Seville.
I had the baddest Seville
in Los Angeles, slant back.
It was the baddest Seville.
It was all Gucci
outside and inside interior with
Alpine, everything.
When you turn it on,
when you started engine
this it looked like a spaceship.
Green lights just lit up,
Brmmm, like a spaceship.
Brmmm
Oh, it was so tight.
It was so tight.
So anyway, Peaches,
this pimp tell Peaches.
He see her walking in the gas station
and pay for the money, while I get out
to start pumping gas in the car.
I just wanted to see her response.
Right. When he told her that girl,
I know you selling pussy,
because your walk, could
make you a million dollars.
I used to tell her the same thing, girl,
you walk sexy as hell.
You know what I'm saying?
You need to quit walking like that.
But she couldn't.
She was just that damn fine.
She couldn't it was just said bam, bam.
Right? Wait.
So anyway, she'd go in to pay the gas.
Yeah. So when she come out
here, she looked at him.
She smirked at him, and she
went in to pay for the gas.
When she came out, she
walked over to his car
switched that to, he turned
his head from one second.
She pulled out a 38.
She pulled out a 38 revolver.
He hit the fool in the head. Bow
You know what I'm saying?
Bitch ass nigga, don't you fuck with me.
Hoe money, hoe money is slow money.
I make dope money.
You know what I'm saying?
And went up side fools heads.
I'm just sitting in the car,
sitting, waiting the car
laughing like a motherfucker
Like hah, laughing,
like, come on, come on.
You know I'm saying?
(laughing)
You know, you see I laugh at this stuff.
So we did a call.
Boom. We rode back to my motel.
I had Peaches and my first wife Anita,
we, we lived together.
You know what I'm saying?
The three of us,
- [Interviewer] Uh huh
- I had a couple of more too
but there wasn't wife's
that yet, but Peaches.
And my first wife, were wife status,
you know what I'm saying?
So I lived with these
two ladies in apartment
on between 104th and 180 Crenshaw
in Inglewood, family,
Crenshaw Mafia neighborhoods
you know what I'm saying?
But they didn't, they didn't mess
with me in they knew
what house I moved in.
You know what I'm saying?
Which was an enemy to them at the time.
I'm a hoover crip.
Now it's who we're pre liminal
and we've elevated ourselves
to a status to where we don't care.
What sets you from.
If you want to get along with us,
you can get along with us.
But if you want to get it on with us.
You get it over with us.
You know what I'm saying?
We got that notorious and
BA you know what I'm saying?
And really, that's really
just one of my jewelry store robbery
I hit nine of them.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't want to talk about all of them.
I just want to tell you that
and about Peaches.
Cause I still love her to this day.
You know what I'm saying?
And if I can ever see her
again, I'm telling you
I want you to meet her
because now she's also
bisexual type stuff
where I've seen her again
where she will still, get me what I want.
As soon as she sees to
me, it's on with us.
You know what I'm saying?
As soon as we see each other, it's on.
I just haven't seen
her in a few years now.
But the other times when I was
in and out of prison,
cause I did 20 years in prison
on the installment plan of in and out.
And when I see her again, it's on.
I want you to meet her man.
She's a cool girl, man.
She's really cool.
Her name is Peaches man.
If you ever played with somebody
and say they know of Harlem's
and Hoovers, you know,
our names would come up.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Thank you so much man.
Great story.
- You're welcome man.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Its fun
You know?
- Yeah. Peaches was a
lover boy she was a...